so Millennials are a generation we
define them as having been born after
1980 so the oldest of them is in his or
her early 30s the youngest mid teenagers
typically generations lasts about 20
years or so we don't really know when
the back half of this generation ends
there's probably a 12 or 13 year old
who's somebody different but he or she
hasn't quite come of age yet it's a very
distinctive generation and the oldest of
them has now made the passage into
adulthood so we know a little bit more
about them than we did eight or ten
years ago when they first came on the
scene distinctive they're very large
generation by the time the 20 year cycle
is done they'll probably be 80 million
strong the largest generation since the
baby boomers they are very distinctive
racially and ethnically they are the
transitional generation in America that
in the middle of the last century was
about 85% white by the middle of this
century will be only a little more than
40% white Millennials are that are the
most non-white generation they're more
than four in 10 or non-white this is
driven by the great modern immigration
wave that's now about four or five
decades old unlike our earlier
immigration waves which are almost
entirely from Europe this immigration
wave is mostly from Latin America and
Asia and it's the immigrants themselves
but more so now it's the children of the
immigrants the u.s. born children of the
immigrants who make up a very heavy
portion of this millennial generation
their distinctive politically they've
not they're now old enough to have voted
in two or three presidential elections
and they were a very big part of both of
President Obama's victories by our
calculation the Pew Research Center
where I work and did a lot of research
that led to this book they are the most
democratic voting a generation of young
adults of anything we have seen in 50 or
60 years of tracking voting patterns
they're very liberal in their social and
cultural values so some of the changes
that are going on in the country on
issues like same-sex marriage marijuana
legalization actually pretty dramatic
changes in a fairly short period of time
in terms of public attitudes it's the
Millennials it's the young adults who
are leading the way
despite their distinctive political and
social views and voting behaviors
however they
not terribly attached to the Democratic
Party even though they gave big votes to
Democratic presidential candidates when
we asked adults of all ages are you a
Democrat a Republican or an independent
Millennials of 50% of Millennials say
I'm independent we've never seen that
high a share from any age cohort we see
a similar thing when we ask about their
religion our you know what are you
partisan Catholic Muslim Hindu Jewish a
record share of Millennials say I'm
nothing in particular and there's a
third anchor institution of society if
you will that Millennials are not
attached to and that's a little old
5,000 year institution called marriage
so of today's eighteen to thirty three
year olds only about a quarter are
married if you go back to older
generations when they were the same age
5 and 10 6 and 10 of the oldest
generation more than 6 and 10 were
married I think the slow walk toward
marriage and the disassociation from
anchor institutions I think are
explained by first their economic
circumstances another distinctive thing
about this generation is they're the
first in modern American history and
perhaps the first in American history
that at least so far we don't know how
their story ends but we know how the
story of their economic lives have begun
and at least so far they are the first
generation in modern times that is doing
less well economically than their
parents generation on anyway you measure
it whether it's income whether it's
wealth whether it's poverty whether it's
employment unemployment all the classic
measures and you correct for inflation
and you make it an apples to apples
comparison they're doing less well the
fact that they're doing less well means
a lot of them when we ask them who those
who aren't married would you like to
marry almost the 7/10 say yes why
haven't you gotten married well look at
me you know I don't have a job I don't
have a career I don't have the economic
foundation to get married and that will
reverberate in interesting ways as they
mature into middle age and beyond
and then finally perhaps if not the most
distinctive thing about this generation
certainly one of the most distinctive
things is they are first generation of
digital natives so they are the only age
group of adults now
for whom those are these amazing gadgets
we now all hold in our hand and we all
take for granted that with the three
clicks you can you can access the sum of
all human knowledge and frankly these
days if it takes you a third click
you're wondering what takes so long
so somebody my age this is jaw-dropping
it's still jaw-dropping every time I
access these information platforms and
do it in mobile sites and and I'm just
amazed these young adults are not amazed
it's the it's the only world they've
ever known and and they they are
carnivores in terms of their habits with
with these information systems not just
for information acquisition but for the
creation of networks they organize their
social lives around these networks they
can build their own tribes somebody more
clever than me described them as a pre
Copernican generation the universe
really does revolve around them because
they can build their social networks and
they can place themselves at the center
of their social networks because their
social networks are built around the
things they care the most about whether
it's their hobbies whether it's their
work whether it's the games they like to
play whether it's information seeking
and all the rest this behavior has led
some to suggest that it's a narcissistic
generation my own view is that that's a
bum rap I think it's all about the new
platforms and it's all about the human
condition and if you have the ability to
kind of place yourself at the center of
the universe you will take it I think
it's it's empowering it may lead to
another trait of the Millennials they're
somewhat distrustful of other people and
it may be because as they navigate the
online world it turns out not everybody
is exactly who they say they are and
there's there's a certain wariness about
this generation and I think there's an
interesting question about whether the
networks that they build online with
their the median millennial has 250
quote-unquote friends on Facebook
somebody my age or older has only a 1/5
that amount of friends and many fewer of
us are on Facebook so you know discuss
among yourselves has there been a
quantum leap in human friendliness over
the past few generations or is it simply
that the new platforms create new
behaviors and new ways of organized
in your social life it's clearly the
latter I think an interesting question I
don't think we know the answer to it yet
is as Millennials age more into into
middle age as they probably age into
some of the more traditional anchor
institutions of society marriage
children homeownership and all the rest
and these things are all happening more
slowly for Millennials will they
establish more of an offline network
that begins to resemble the networks and
the affiliations and associations that
their parents and grandparents built